now I oughta murders you all gonna be
singing for us I am oh oh kiss cap
[Applause]
back off lady
oh yeah so we so we have to do the scene
where she kisses Daisy kisses him and
you know you don't just kiss me nada
DiCaprio yes there we were sort of
halfway through the scene and I was sort
of like here
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I was in a scene where I was in bed
listening to the radio because the voice
of the man reading the shipping forecast
really turned me on this is the work I
do so I was in bed and I had to be being
turned on and I was getting slightly
embarrassed and shy I was pregnant I was
feeling mad as you are and Graham came
over to and he said him okay the noises
that you're making could you could you
make the noises that you might make
getting into a hot bath and that was it
I was like
[Laughter]
[Applause]
there are going to be so many suspicious
husbands tonight just thinking sound
familiar
getting into a hot bath
that was very lazy when they act like
they're getting into a cold bath with me
[Applause]
meteorologist that was what I thought
that I was going to be my entire life I
wanted to study I've learned a lot from
you I know but I was honored to know and
I was working on the same project she's
kind of taken
[Laughter]
my trail that leads to youth and
arguments in the past with your wife I
have yes the biggest one I found is that
if you're having an argument about an
issue stick to the issue don't start
getting personal and a spiteful that's
the one in it yeah so we were arguing
and I just sort of lost it I was and I
said Oh sharp monkey feet
I didn't pick this out of the air my
wife has got massive toes and Carly
you're single now meeting people and
dating is hard enough but Cameron Diaz
and I'm single
I'm going to include you it wasn't sure
lucky for you Russell unmarried like a
power
[Applause]
I could feel the mist every time we kiss
just didn't know it down for like this
there's a there's a flash-forward
warning will it will rain in the morning
and there'll be puddles in the bed
you're amazing explain how people
discover this extraordinary birds of
paradise and what the male birds of
paradise - oh it's upside down and
whistle that's good nice nice and the
other one is another male of species has
got long quills coming out of his tail
and what he does is to turn round and
then flick his friend the cost of you
have a few yeah what's the most
impressive thing do be that one but I
might want someone to spot me yes
okay just put your arm kind of like that
put my arm like that
okay wait maybe a little bit more like
this is pretty exciting baby
and then just I'm gonna hit your arm for
once I'm ready to catch you or done easy
from going over that way and then I can
balance okay oh this is fantastic
this is home
[Music]
[Applause]
I want it soaking wet all over the beds
do you sing lyrics
you